- No, I have to say I
was watching The Chair.
And um, it was random.
I just started watching the show.
And this was a minute ago in my house.
And all of sudden, your
whole thing start to come up.
And they start describing you.
And I had no idea like all
these things about you.
I had no idea that you went to Princeton.
I had no idea you were a novelist.
I didn't know these things about you.
I only knew you as a actor.
- I like to keep it quiet.
- I know, I'm like. But it's amazing.
I literally googled. I'm
like is this for the show?
Or is this real?
And I googled you like
stalker, and you're amazing.
- Well um, another thing
Amanda did- she went.
I went to Princeton undergraduate,
and I wrote a senior thesis, a long paper
like a 100 page paper on
Samuel Beckett. And she went-
And you can get it from the library.
You can't take it out. But
I guess you can xerox it.
If anybody remembers what a
xerox is, uh back in the day.
- I love a little kinos.
(light laughing)
- So yeah, she xeroxed it.
It was on the set, you know?
I hadn't seen it since I
handed it in 150 years ago.
And I got to look at it
again, and I have to say,
I didn't understand a word of it.
(hysterical laughing)
- I was very confusing.
- So, they were reading your work?
- It was my work.
- That's amazing.
- Well, when Sandra Oh comes in,
and she kinda throws it
on the table, that's it.
That's the thing. That's my
paper. It was the actual thing.
And I was just reading
it in-between takes.
I was like, this is crap.
- Oh, my gosh. We're all
hardest on ourselves.
Well, someone tweeted
that they came across
one of your old Yale textbooks.
That's amazing.
Like did they just find you that way?
What did they just tweet you or something?
- No, I guess when I left New Haven,
I guess I sold my books.
Cause he brought that in a used bookstore.
- You sell your books for money.
You're not going to keep it, yeah.
- I guess. That was a good
book. I wish I'd kept that one.
- Oh.
I'm sure they give it to you.
(soft laugh)
- What was interesting about
that guy is my daughter is now
acting. She acting on
this show for Netflix,
about the Sackler family and the Oxycontin
and this guy who had my book, uh he.
His book is actually the
main source of information
for that series.
- What?
- Crazy coincidence. Yeah.
- What kind of happen stance is that?
How does that occur? That's crazy.
- I don't know how it occurred.
- Wow! It's a small world.
- Okay. Okay
I think you should get the book back.
I'm going to start a hashtag.
- I'd like the book back.
- I want the book back for Duchovny.